MARTIN: Hey, Katie.
Thanks for jumping on the call.
KATIE: No worries, Martin.
I heard you needed help
setting up your new website.
MARTIN: Yeah, I have this
repo here, my-travels.
And all the code
is here on GitHub.
But I want somewhere
to run this code.
And I also wanted to
set up so that when
I push a new version
here to GitHub,
the new version gets deployed
automatically to the cloud.
KATIE: Well, that's easy.
We can set that all
up for in Cloud Run.
I can show you right
now in your browser.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So I see you've got your
code there, all on GitHub.
And you're logged into
Cloud Console, right?
MARTIN: Uh, on Google's
Cloud Platform?
KATIE: Yeah.
MARTIN: Let me look.
Yep, and I even created an
empty project here, my-travels.
I haven't done anything
with it, except create it.
KATIE: OK, great.
So if you want to go over
into the Cloud Run section
and create a new service,
we can get started.
MARTIN: All right.
Very good.
Let's see.
Cloud Run is down here.
Actually, I'll pin it, as well,
so that it's easy to get to.
So here we are in the
Cloud Run section.
There's nothing here yet.
KATIE: Yeah, so if you just want
to go and click Create service.
MARTIN: Create service.
OK.
Up here, very nice.
Enabling the Cloud Run API.
And what do I do here?
KATIE: So under
Service name, you
said this was your
travel website, so if you
want to name it My Travels.
MARTIN: Oh, OK.
Very good.
Cloud Run API has been enabled.
my-travels.
OK.
KATIE: Yep.
MARTIN: Next.
Oh, container.
I don't think I have
a container image.
KATIE: Well, that's OK.
You don't have to
have one already.
What we can do is, if you
see just below that Deploy
container, it has an
option there saying,
Continuously deploy
from source control.
MARTIN: Ah, yes,
that's what I want.
KATIE: Yeah.
MARTIN: All right.
Set up with Cloud Build?
KATIE: So now you're
going to want to--
yep.
So go and Set up
with Cloud Build.
MARTIN: All right.
Very good.
And I guess I need to
enable some APIs here.
KATIE: Yeah.
MARTIN: Oh, this
is looking good.
It says GitHub.
This is what I want.
But no repositories
available, Katie.
KATIE: Well, see that
other big blue button,
Install Google Cloud Build?
You're going to need to install
Cloud Build as part of GitHub.
So if you want to click that.
MARTIN: All right.
Click the big, blue
friendly button?
KATIE: Yeah.
MARTIN: Yeah.
And here, so now it
took me to GitHub.
And here, I want to do it
specifically for my-travels.
Very good.
Read and write, I guess?
KATIE: Yeah.
MARTIN: All right.
Let's see if-- oh, look at that.
That's my GitHub repo.
Very nice.
I understand that
members blah, blah, blah.
Yes.
Sounds good.
And Next, or Advanced
Options here?
KATIE: Just click Next.
MARTIN: Next.
OK, good.
Very good.
OK, Build Configuration,
Dockerfile, huh.
What's all this about?
KATIE: OK, so for the branch,
you're using a main branch.
So you're going to
want to make sure
that you-- yep, in
that selection there,
it's worked out what
your main branch is.
MARTIN: Oh, it figured that out.
Excellent.
KATIE: Yeah.
So what this part will
do is, anytime you
push to your main branch, your
service will be redeployed.
MARTIN: Oh, that's
exactly what I want.
Let's see.
I don't have a Dockerfile.
KATIE: That's OK.
You don't need a Dockerfile.
What we can do is we can use
Cloud Buildpacks instead.
MARTIN: Oh, what are Buildpacks?
KATIE: They're a standard
way of being able to build
your container images.
You might be familiar
with them if you've used
something like Heroku before.
Your codebase doesn't
need to change,
but you will have
to add one file.
MARTIN: OK, got it.
So root is the build directory?
KATIE: Yeah.
MARTIN: Yeah?
KATIE: But before we
continue with this, Martin,
if you want to go
back to your codebase,
we're going to need
to add that one file.
MARTIN: Oh, OK.
Got it.
So here's my code.
I have my readme file here.
No Dockerfile or whatever.
The other files are not
here that you mentioned.
KATIE: That's OK.
So I see in your readme,
you've got exactly the command
that you need to run
your application.
Yeah?
MARTIN: Right.
This is how I run my app.
KATIE: And you run this--
you run this after you install
your dependencies, right?
MARTIN: Mhm.
That's right.
KATIE: OK.
So what we're
going to need to do
is create a special file that
will tell Buildpacks to run
that python3 flask run command.
MARTIN: OK, got it.
KATIE: So create
a new file called
Procfile with a capital P.
MARTIN: All right.
So let's see here.
Procfile.
Yep.
KATIE: Yeah.
MARTIN: Does it have
a file extension?
KATIE: Nope, just Procfile.
MARTIN: Just Procfile.
OK, here we are in the Procfile.
KATIE: And if you want to copy
that command from your readme
into this Procfile.
MARTIN: Yeah.
KATIE: Yeah, and then at
the start of that line,
type in web, colon, space.
MARTIN: Like so?
KATIE: Yeah.
So what this will do is,
when the Buildpack runs,
it will try to find a
Procfile, and then it
will execute the command
that you've tagged as web.
Web, in this case, stands
for the web service.
And this is the command
it will run when you
want to start your web service.
We will need to add one
other thing to this command,
and that's just a
host and a port.
These are specific things
that Cloud Run needs to run.
As part of what
Cloud Run needs, it
says that I will run
anything that you
put in a container that's
serving on host 0.0.0.0
and listening on a port.
So after run, if you
want to type --host.
MARTIN: Host, yep.
Got it.
KATIE: Yep.
=0.0.0.0.
MARTIN: OK, very good.
KATIE: Yeah.
And then a space, --port=$PORT
MARTIN: So that's an
environment variable?
KATIE: Yeah.
So we could add
these configurations
within your Flask app.py itself.
Or we can get the
Procfile to run Flask
with these
configurations for us.
MARTIN: Hm, seems to make
sense to break it out
into its own file.
OK, I like this.
Was that it for the Procfile?
KATIE: Yeah.
So what you need to
do is save this file,
and commit it to
your repository,
and then push it up to GitHub.
MARTIN: Oh, OK.
Got it.
So Add Procfile is
what I'll call it.
Commit that.
Make sure I push that up.
It's thinking about it.
OK.
Let's see here.
KATIE: If youi
jump over, refresh.
MARTIN: Yeah, let's
see if it made it up.
Oh, look at that.
Procfile.
KATIE: Yeah.
MARTIN: It made it.
KATIE: Awesome.
So that's the only change you
need to make to your code.
So if you want to jump back
over into Cloud Console,
we can continue with
the set-up process.
MARTIN: Oh, that's right.
We didn't go through
with the whole thing.
Yeah, what should I do here?
KATIE: All these
defaults are fine,
so if you want to click Save.
MARTIN: OK.
Let's see, Where's Save?
Down there.
Mhm.
Cloud Trigger will be created
once you create the service.
OK.
KATIE: Yeah, so if you
scroll down a smidge.
MARTIN: Yeah.
KATIE: And click Next.
MARTIN: Oh, OK.
Next.
KATIE: And then this is
your public website, right?
MARTIN: Yeah, that's right.
I want everybody to know
about where I've traveled.
KATIE: Yep.
So you're going
to want to select
Allow unauthenticated
invocations.
So that just means that
everyone can see your website.
MARTIN: Ah, OK.
KATIE: And then click Create.
MARTIN: All right.
KATIE: And then we can sit
back and watch this all happen.
MARTIN: Oh, OK.
Creating, dot, dot, dot.
Uh-huh.
Oh, so Setting IAM policy.
OK, and then some other
stuff going on here.
So what's going on right now?
KATIE: OK.
So because we didn't have a
container to start off with,
what Cloud Run needs to
do is deploy a service
with a placeholder container.
This container, if
you end up seeing it,
means that it's a placeholder.
But also, it means that you have
somewhere that your service can
sit if something goes wrong.
And the placeholder will
have some debugging steps
if you need some help.
But what it's doing
now is, after it's
created this Build
Cloud Trigger, which
will fire this process any
time your code changes, what
it's doing is it's building
and deploying from repository.
So Buildpacks understand
specific language setups,
like Python, and Java,
and Go, and some others.
What it will do is
it's worked out,
because you have
a Python setup, it
will use a Python environment.
It will install
your dependencies
that you have in your
requirements.txt.
And then as the entry
point on your container,
it will run that command that
you specified in the Procfile.
This Buildpack will build
the container for you,
and then that will
be the container
that Cloud Run deploys.
So all you had to do was
add that one command to get
this all started.
So Cloud Run will deploy
anything that has a container,
but you don't have to use
Docker to build that container.
You can use something
like Buildpacks.
MARTIN: Ah, I see.
And yeah, Buildpacks maybe
make it a little easier.
You don't have to know
Docker to do this.
KATIE: You don't have to.
You just need to tell it-- you
need to use a standard language
that it understands implicitly.
So it understands, for Java, how
to install Java dependencies;
for Python, how to install
Python dependencies.
But it doesn't know how to run
your service, because there
are so many different ways that
you could start a web server.
So that's why you need
to tell it explicitly
when you want to
start my web server,
here is the command
that you want to run.
And in your case,
it was run flask.
MARTIN: Oh, right.
That was-- oh, yes, this--
KATIE: Yeah.
MARTIN: --piece that
I run otherwise.
Got it.
KATIE: Yeah.
MARTIN: All right.
And let's see, it's Pending.
KATIE: There we go.
MARTIN: Oh, so let's see.
So it is done
building my code now?
KATIE: Yeah.
So if you want to click on
that URL there that starts with
my-travels--
MARTIN: Oh, you
even gave me a URL.
KATIE: --you'll
have your website.
MARTIN: Nice.
Let's have a look.
Ah, look at that.
It is my travel website.
This is amazing.
So I really like this.
Now, what if I want to make
updates to either the content,
or if I want to make
updates to the code here?
What do I do?
KATIE: Well, now that we've set
up that Cloud Build Trigger,
all you need to do to
redeploy your website
is update the code
in your main branch
on your remote repository.
So last time we did this,
you were in the VS Code.
If you want to jump
over into GitHub now,
we can make a small change
and redeploy your website.
MARTIN: Oh, cool.
OK, so like you said,
I could do in VS Code,
but let's do it over here.
So, yeah, I like how it
says My Travels there.
But it's not quite--
I don't know, not
quite personal enough.
But I want to make it
a little more personal.
So what if I go into
the home template here,
and I edit it, not from VS
Code, but from GitHub directly.
Can do it in either
place, I guess.
And I will say Martin's Travels.
And then OK, and here,
it will loop over.
Very good.
Let's scroll down here.
I'll commit that change.
KATIE: You see that little
yellow dot that's appeared?
MARTIN: Oh, yeah.
That's new.
What's that?
KATIE: That is the status symbol
that your Cloud Build Trigger
is currently processing.
MARTIN: Ah.
KATIE: So if you click that,
you can see more details.
MARTIN: Oh, right.
Details, OK.
KATIE: And then if you
click on View more details,
it will take you back into
the Google Cloud Console,
and will show your
Running build log.
MARTIN: So here I'm seeing
the build log as it's running.
OK.
New stuff is popping
up in this window.
It's looking good so far.
No error messages,
as far as I can see.
KATIE: No.
And you can see the steps there.
The first step is Buildpack,
which builds the container.
The second one is push,
which pushes the container.
And then the third
one is deploy.
That will use that container
and then redeploy your service.
And this is going to
happen any time you update
the main branch on your repo.
So you can edit in VS
Code and push it up.
You can edit it in the
command line and push it up.
You can edit it
directly in GitHub.
Anywhere that will be a
commit on that main branch
of the remote repository.
So you have to remember to push
your code for it to trigger.
But anytime you edit
that code, this trigger
will redeploy everything.
MARTIN: And now I made an
edit to a template here.
If I made an edit
to Python code,
would it rebuild
the Python code?
KATIE: It will
rebuild everything
from your source repository.
MARTIN: Oh, it's done.
KATIE: Yeah.
So if you refresh your website,
your change should be there.
MARTIN: All right.
Let's have a look.
Martin's Travels.
Great success.
Thank you for showing me, Katie.
This was really easy.
KATIE: No worries.
I hope you get to add more
things to your travels soon,
but you can now update
your website automatically
with Cloud Build and Cloud Run.
MARTIN: Excellent.
Thank you for watching.
If you have suggestions
on what we should bring up
in future episodes, or if
you have questions about what
we did here in this episode,
please add them in the comments
below.
Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]